Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new batman video for the flash movie
we just got our first footage of ben affleck's
batman there's a bunch of easter eggs so we'll
break it all down we also know what he's doing
in the other parts of the movie as well so i'll
explain that if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
it's just getting started we're getting ready for
a big dc fandom event in october that's when we'll
be seeing more footage for the matt reeves batman
movie probably the next big trailer also probably
some sort of teaser trailer for the flash movie
also explain what's going on during the timeline
of the flash movie here and where this fits
in relative to the justice league snyder cut
ending scenes the epilogue the post-credits scenes
because they had that whole epilogue showing all
the characters and what they were doing next
right after the events of the movie and even
though i think everybody understands this if it
wasn't clear the flash movie is directly connected
to the zack snyder dc movies like justice league
batman v superman man of steel so that's the whole
reason that they're bringing ben affleck's batman
back because they're also doing a flashpoint story
so i know there's a lot of questions about how
much of the flashpoint story they're doing but if
you weren't aware they've been filming the flash
movie for a good long while now we've got a whole
bunch of teasers and scenes so far i've done a
couple videos for those so i'll put links in the
description below we've seen ezra miller's flash
inside michael keaton's batcave just freaking out
like wait a minute what's going on where am i but
what's happening in these new ben affleck batman
scenes that they just released during the flash
movies he's chasing down these criminals driving
this military spec humvee through the streets
of gotham city if you couldn't tell from the
architecture this is meant to be gotham city his
gotham city on the justice league earth because
this is a multiverse movie we'll be visiting
multiple versions of earth the whole thing
with ben affleck's batman though you probably
noticed is that the new bat cycle probably looks
familiar it looks like a combination of the bat
cycle from batman white knight and some unused
concept art from the justice league snyder cut
you may remember zack snyder had a bat cycle
that almost made it into the movie it's a little
bit shorter and stubbier than this one and it
doesn't use wheels it uses jets to maneuver around
but you can see how zack snyder thought this out
it would have remotely summoned to him wherever
he was and he'd mount it vertically like this
and then shift it into the horizontal position and
take off he probably couldn't use it to fly super
high in the atmosphere or anything like a true jet
but he could probably use it to make some pretty
wicked jumps it just seems like andy muschietti
the flash movie people decided to take a more
traditional approach with their bat cycle but zoom
and enhance it's got two wheels in the front an
extra fat one in the back and it's covered in the
same type of armor as his ship the batmobile from
justice league snyder cut it's made from the same
material makes sense it was also the very frank
miller dark knight returns bat tank from the end
of the justice league snyder cut too you have to
imagine that that exists somewhere in this world
too the version of the batman suit that it looks
like he's wearing is slightly tuned up hybrid
of his batman v superman leather armor suit the
frank miller looking dark knight return suit in
the hardcore armor suit from justice league like
a lighter weight suit with extra armor laid on top
to protect his arms back exposed areas while he's
riding the bat cycle you can also see the scaled
looking armor plating protecting his spine at his
back and even though you don't see his cape he
could be going capeless yes but my early guesses
is that they're just doing the cape as a special
effect because it's easier to film that way
they're also doing the exact same thing for
supergirl's cape in the movie too if you haven't
seen the supergirl scenes that were released
earlier this year you can see her during a couple
different scenes a fight scene and then just a
regular scene of her floating in the air and while
she's on the wires here being hoisted up as if
she were flying there's a couple of these moments
where she doesn't have a cape on set just because
they're gonna add it with special effects later if
you don't remember zack snyder often did the same
thing for henry cavill superman scenes when he was
doing a fight scene or there was a lot of action
he would just go capeless and then add the cape
later with special effects the design language of
her superman suit her crest is the same as henry
cavill superman it just tunes slightly differently
in the color scheme of her suit looks a little bit
more like the injustice super girl suit they
haven't completely explained whether or not
she comes from michael keaton batman earth or if
she's going to come from somewhere else in the
multiverse or if she comes from the main justice
league earth we'll probably find out about that
when they release the first trailer the reason why
i think this ben affleck scene might be happening
earlier in the movie is just because i think they
want to show you the things for ben affleck's
batman after the events of the justice league
snyder cut post credit scene or just business as
usual in gotham like they're not gonna do any of
the huge overarching plot from the justice league
sequels in the flash movie like the big dark side
stuff that they were teasing they'll probably
reference some of the previous adventures they
had like fighting aliens just a little while ago
but i think a little time will have gone by and
he's just been doing his regular batman crime
fighting activities since the end of justice
league like what better way to convey that than
to introduce him in the movie in the middle of a
chase scene or a fight scene with him being full
batman just business as usual going around beating
the crap out of criminals the other big thing
that andy muschietti the director said they're
doing with his batman in the movie is that ben
affleck's batman is going to give the flash his
brand new flash suit like he'll build it for him
the one that they showed off in the teaser at
dc fandom last year i'm just gonna call that his
multiverse suit for now as you can see it's a huge
upgrade you can see the speed force energy arcing
all over it it looks a little bit more comic booky
i'm assuming that a lot of this will be done with
special effects and that's probably why we haven't
seen him wearing it around in broad daylight yet
they also said that ben affleck's batman has
this huge emotional component of the movie
my assumption is that's part of the flashpoint
storyline with the death of barry's mother because
batman lost both of his parents and obviously
because we have michael keaton's batman who has
pretty much the exact same backstory he lost both
his parents as well in crime alley just like ben
affleck's batman i don't know if they're
gonna do the actual letter scene to sort of
tag things at the end from the comic book in the
animated justice league flashpoint movie but in
that original story it was thomas wayne his father
batman's father who wrote him the letter what they
might wind up doing early theory is that they'll
just do a twist on that where michael keaton's
older batman writes his younger self ben affleck's
batman a version of that letter why is old batman
writing his younger self some advice on life i
know a lot of people are wondering if this is
going to be ben affleck's last time as batman my
assumption now is never say never but i think for
now they'll just end the movie he will still be
batman on the main justice league earth it's not
like they're going to kill him off or retcon him
or anything like that so i wouldn't worry about
that kind of stuff you may remember just a little
while ago too there was a bunch of special trailer
footage that leaked out and yes i did see it but i
can't put it in this video it just shows the flash
in his new flash suit teaming up with michael
keaton's batman who's in a version of the bat
pod his jet from the batman 1989 movie also
with supergirl all of them teaming up for a
big fight scene there were a lot of other scenes
that they showed inside michael keaton's bat cave
with them walking around it looks like an upgraded
version of the batcave scenes from the batman 1989
movie as you would expect i think they'll release
that footage at the new dc fandom event happening
in october this year this is him as bruce wayne
towards the end of the movie at the central city
courthouse steps as ezra miller's flash comes
out with iris west at the end of his father's
trial and after they've cleared his name in the
death of barry's mother because that's obviously
a big part of the film too barry's still trying
to get his father out of prison supergirl is also
here in this scene too barry seems happy that's
why everyone thinks this is from later in the
movie as opposed to the beginning of the movie if
you're not a car person either that new car that
michael keaton's bruce wayne is driving this is a
brand new mercedes-maybach model so batman driving
really expensive really cool cars has always been
a thing michael keane's batman obviously coming
from the earth where all the tim burton batman
movies took place i'm just going to call that the
burton verse for now we could also call that earth
89 that's what they did during crisis on infinite
earth and because of the ezra miller grant gustin
crossover scene from crisis on infinite earths you
could say that all of that is canon to the justice
league multiverse that they're doing in the flash
movie everything is canon now because of the
multiverse we joke but that's kind of the concept
that they were talking about during the last big
dc fandom event last year when they released the
first teaser trailer for the movie during that
crisis on infinite earth scene they just had a
michael keaton batman earth 89 cameo scene that
was robert wole's alexander knox from the batman
1989 movie reading the gotham globe newspaper from
the movie there were also a bunch of other scenes
and big easter eggs that didn't make it into
the actual episodes like this other newspaper
saying that he was about to get married to
selena kyle's catwoman and if you don't remember
the other things they've said about michael
keaton's batman in the movie what they've
explained is the movie will treat batman forever
and batman and robin as if those movies happen in
another reality they're just using the events of
the tim burton batman movies for michael keaton's
batman continuity in his timeline maybe if things
go well they do more sequels to the flash movie
we'll see more michael keaton batman characters
from his earth come back like michelle pfeiffer
made it seem like she would love to come back as
catwoman but i don't think that she's supposed
to be in this new flash movie right now the
movie is scheduled to come out in november
next year so we'll see more trailers and footage
later this year and also a lot of footage for the
matt reeves batman movie i think i'm allowed to
post my suicide squad movie review this wednesday
the embargo should be up make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that i
will do more suicide squad videos as the movie
starts to come out once you do have a chance to
see it make sure you write your reactions in the
comments below but please do not post spoilers
everyone click here for my new loki video all
about how iron man knew about kang in the mcu and
click here to learn about the full plot of what
justice league snyder cut 2 and justice league
3 would have been thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!